hi this is dave baker and today we're
going to take a look at some of the most
iconic chinese weapons seen on forged
and fire
now the chinese culture has a documented
history that goes back thousands of
years and in those years they've
developed a wide array of weapons
so let's take a look at some of the
weapons we've had on forging fire
this is the chinese dowel the very first
chinese dowels were made of bronze and
used during the shang dynasty the handle
of the chinese down combat was often
wrapped in silk it was believed to bring
luck and bravery to the user
in martial arts movies the dow is often
depicted as having this wobbly flexible
tip
though flexible these blades were stout
cutting machines
these are chinese favorite of mine
the butterfly swords these swords were
designed to be carried in one sheet they
could be drawn and used with one hand
they could also be offensive or
defensive weapons the design of the
guard on the butterfly sword has a
knuckle bow to protect the hand and the
knuckles a rear quillian that allows the
sword to be dropped into a defensive
position but also
defend from another blade
nice
now the butterfly swords were very
popular in southern china in the mid
19th century where many martial arts
forms were built around their use
as far as short sword design goes
these give you both an attack
and a defense
makes for a good blade
these interesting blades
are deer horn knives
designed by the creator of the martial
art bagua zhang these blades were both
defensive and offensive in nature
consisting of sharpened points and long
curved blades that not only cut and
thrust but protected the hand
now the story is told that the creator
of these weapons was a tax collector and
he used these for personal protection
while collecting taxes for the chinese
emperor
i think i'd pay my taxes
this is the tai chi sword the jin the
jin dao the scholar sword
one of the oldest sword designs in china
and one of the oldest sword designs
still in use on the planet it consists
of a long straight double-edged blade
with a thrusting point a small guard for
the hand and a single hand handle these
blades were designed to be light and
fast
there are many martial arts built around
this blade the biggest being tai chi now
these swords became a status symbol in
the late 19th century and were carried
by educated gentlemen and often used in
self-defense or in dueling and that's
how they got their name the scholars
sword
now these nasty looking things are
called hook swords usually these weapons
are used in martial arts demonstrations
forms like wushu often use these hooking
them spinning them and doing forms
i'm good with that
the hook sword has a hook that's
sharpened on the outside a blade
sharpened on the inside
and that crescent which protects the
hand is also sharpened
then on the back a point giving you
multiple places to attack and or defend
when used together this pair of weapons
could be used both to hook an opponent
as well as attacking
you